Samuel leaves here and I have just
invested into Bitcoin cryptocurrencies I
get asked about this all the time I'm
not an absolute expert but I have spent
quite a bit of time talking with people
that do know a lot about cryptos and
Bitcoin it's really funny because the
first day I bought two I bought two
coins which was actually quite expensive
because I got in late I bought them for
about 7,000 pound each I know some
people that like bought loads of them
you know the the firt the first the
first day I bought them the following
day they'd gone up by about 400 pounds I
was like yes bingo this is great and
then now they've dropped now they're on
at 12440 for when I up at 14 so I'm
feeling a little bit bummed out but the
thing is with Bitcoin is you can't
really watch it every day and be like oh
yes greatly no no not so good would
advise you invest in Bitcoin what are my
thoughts on it I'll take the good first
then I'll tell you they're not so good
and then I'll give you my wrapped up
conclusion thoughts the good is my main
problem I had with Bitcoin beforehand I
mean I was sat down next to a guy who in
South Africa maybe maybe three or four
weeks ago and he said that he bought
Bitcoin like nine years ago when it
first came out and he invested 800
pounds and now he showed me his account
he's got net it's like 20 I think it's
24 million so I'm suddenly 24 million
just through Bitcoin and I said that's
fantastic you're very wealthy now you're
a multimillionaire
but what value if you add it you know
what what value have you brought to the
world how have you helped people have
you added a society and he answered me
but I didn't get it and for me I only
want to do something when I'm adding
value because I believe that money
follows value if that's not the case I
don't understand it if I don't
understand it I'm out however after
talking with some of the guys like Louie
Thomas and Marcos de Maria I do kind of
understand a little bit more now about
how it does add value because the thing
is with crypto currencies it's a way of
making payment very very simply a bit
like PayPal but even easier anywhere in
the world so it's a really
straightforward way of making payment
whereby currencies are not needed so
that kind of makes sense because bitcoin
isn't a currency so I kind of get that
now so I guess it does add value I don't
think the Bitcoin is going to disappear
because there's a lot of people that
live their whole lives based on Bitcoin
there
villages that just everything they buy
us through Bitcoin and it I spin out
it's been around nine nine years it's
getting stronger and stronger I don't
think it's going to Sapir I don't think
it's gonna crash I think it's probably
going to go up I think it will continue
to go up that's my that's my thoughts
but who knows I might get overtaken by
another coin who knows so so I guess
that's kind of the good I have invested
myself into Bitcoin just a couple coins
I'm gonna watch them a lot my pets the
bad is that you don't get any rent off
Bitcoin so you know the thing I love
about property investing is you get paid
twice you get paid once in rent passive
income cache of cash flow but then you
also get paid because when the
properties go up in value you then get
paid capital appreciation of course
you've got taxes on that capital gains
tax but you've got textures on Bitcoin
you've got taxes on pretty much anything
if you're making money I'm happy to pay
tax so so that's the one thing I don't
like the fact that you can't like the
guy who went up and he made 28 million
that is not cash that he could spend so
unless he sells so that that's a slight
problem and then the other problem I
think is that there is risk with it now
there's risk with any investment there's
more there's risk with money in the bank
there's risk in property the thing you
need to do is educate yourself so you
can minimize the risk but even people
that are making really good money in
Bitcoin and crypto will not deny that it
could crash you they could lose their
money and for me I wouldn't feel
comfortable making it make making all my
money in crypto currencies I want to
diversify it a little bit whereas I
think property is very safe properties
bricks mortar you can see it you can
touch it you can feel it even if the
economy crashes you're still going to
get your rent in fact in recessions
usually rents go up because people can't
afford to buy so my general advice
wrapping it all up to you guys would
probably be I think you should invest in
Bitcoin I was really surprised how easy
it was to buy I thought it's gonna take
weeks I thought doesn't have to set up a
really complicated account it's gonna be
really hard it's not it's a real easy
process
I bought two bitcoins within within a
few hours so it's really straightforward
and it's quite nice watching on your
phone seen what's going don't get
emotionally involved do invest in it I
would probably say but don't invest more
than you cannot afford to lose so I
bought two bitcoins but you can buy one
or you can buy just you can put
ten pounds into Bitcoin you can invest a
little little amount something which you
wouldn't really notice if it was gone
but if Bitcoin does go crazy and it goes
up to a hundred thousand pounds then you
know that then you've made some money
also you can buy things with Bitcoin so
if Bitcoin goes up like crazy Richard
Branson I don't know if I told you this
before but Richard Branson invited me to
go to space with him when he's been the
do the space rides and I think it costs
like two hundred thousand pounds so my
thoughts are Richard Branson has just
announced that you can pay for going to
space through a Bitcoin so if by the
time he goes to space my Bitcoin has
gone up I'll be paying Richard Branson
in Bitcoin so that's my thoughts so I
hope that's helpful and see you next
time thank you so much for watching if
you benefited from that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time